[Music]
today's episode is brought to you by the
US Army hey guys so do the Austral
commentary for so low low low low low
that's a topical reference right yeah
apple bottom jeans yeah Dan's were in
boots with the fur yeah Jose were in the
amplify gene the whole club was looking
at her yeah we're here to get low we're
gonna be talking about the honest
trailer for solo would you hopefully
just watch if you stick around the end
you'll get some deleted scenes some
little bits that didn't make it into the
final cut and beforehand we're going to
talk about solo the movie you guys hated
know you hated you disliked I was
annoyed
maybe we have a we have a we have a wide
range today guys you were entertained I
had low expectations and they were they
were hopped over got it they cleared
that low bar got it I was like oh this
is fun
I always uh I always get weird about
expect like setting expectations for
films because mine is just like I want
it to be good alright like I don't know
if my expectation is like really low
like well this will exist like I don't
watch it I guess or go see it fair
enough I try not to walk in with
expectations yeah appear for this world
yeah you are yeah this was like not even
like not even like a wet fart of a movie
is like a silent part of a movie it's
kind of yeah slipped out and acted kind
of in offensive in offensively and some
people were kind of curled up their
noses but most people just didn't even
notice it yeah that's kind of how I felt
about it I didn't I just didn't I don't
know I think just based on the the
source material the potential for this
was to be such a disaster that it like
ruins Han Solo and oh my god this is the
most unnecessary movie and I won't say
this was a necessary movie I think the
box office bears it out this didn't have
to exist but this didn't ruin Han Solo
for me this was just like oh it's a
young Han Solo adventure the same way
there's like a young James Bond or a
young iconic character insert here he
learned the game from his uncle James
we spared of the name James Bond jr.
anything I guess but it sure as hell
didn't like help Star Wars in any
interesting ways I think it it pumped
the brakes a lot of things and it makes
you point at a lot of stuff in Star Wars
and you go wait what I like is the whole
thing with his name like that was stupid
this was worse that's a terrible
terrible movie scene and it's what they
sold the movie on which is crazy to me
because who puts solo on a form
literally no one who's ever done like
unaccompanied unaccompanied Honaker han
unaccompanied and martin troopers like
katie 41 like why they didn't surname
like no they didn't care about they were
all numbers yes the whole thing about
being in empires you were a number yeah
and a person at a point maybe it's like
Game of Thrones bastards where there's
like thousands of other solos oh yeah
just give them four more expanded
I mean before he met Leia you know he's
rebounding off Kira there maybe just the
the droid thing like the more you shine
a light on it the more you're like
everyone I love in Star Wars is an
[ __ ] that owns a slave I always
assume that from scene I mean is c-3po
not sentient oh no he is and they do but
you don't keep pointing at it they
scream when they burden their final hot
irons I know but if you're just like
this movie just points out it but
doesn't make a point about it they just
it's another lay and the great Star Wars
tradition of just casual treatment of
slavery this is not good unless it's
Anakin's mom that's Darth Vader yes
how many droid Vader's are out there
because of how some rebel pilot scooped
up one of their relatives and stuck them
in the back of a x-wing fire until they
got their top blown off and some lots of
dusty Imperial I don't like sand
it's coarse and runs and gets in my
circuitry yeah you know it's a badly put
together movie that's poorly lit and no
one has an arc or changes or does
anything interesting or meaningful or
needed yeah that's my thing it's like I
just felt like I I walked in knowing who
Soula was and it didn't really give me
anything that enhanced that knowledge so
then it was just like watching a han
Solo adventure with a guy who isn't bad
but is doing sort of a personation of
Harrison Ford and Donald Glover doing an
impersonation of Billy Dee Williams and
a kind of second-rate space adventure
for me it was like it just wasn't really
anything special at least the Hobbit has
um you don't know built like you know
where the rings gonna end up you know
this you know that like you know they're
obviously he's gonna get the ring he's
gonna survive because you know he's
gonna hand it off to Frodo but like you
don't necessarily if you've only seen
Lord of the Rings you don't necessarily
know Bill Bowes arc so at least
vitalizes rubies either shred of like I
mean at least there's that you can mind
but does Han a need an arc past what we
saw in the original trilogy because
that's kind of the arc that matters yeah
I mean it's more of an ensemble movie
than Han even though he's at the center
of all of it I would have loved it if
they had really leaned into that yeah
it's weird Castle run you know story
yeah they are passing kind of the story
baton back and forth from Mike Hahn to
Beckett to Lando to Darth Maul dark that
was I mean I don't know where what look
I'll get on that too
if you've seen Clone Wars and rebels
there's no more story to tell with Darth
Maul they've done so much cool
meaningful stuff with him from beginning
to end and there's no there's there's
even less story to tell with Darth Maul
now than there is with Han Solo so it's
like the dumbest yeah not not in the in
theaters no no not in theaters yeah
that's just that if you bring back Darth
Maul and you don't have flip around and
chop people and a half and what's the
point yeah that's what that's the one
thing I know about Darth Maul's he's
real flipping let's get into the trailer
well we'll start and stop as we see fit
and and tell you more of what we think
about so low low low
you love the original trilogy with a
burning passion
you went to war over the last Jedi now
get ready for a completely new kind of
Star Wars movie one you'll forget by the
time you're home from the theater solo a
Star Wars story oh yeah that did come
out this year didn't it not half of the
Star Wars story because they didn't like
what the director did watch them hand
the keys to an exciting new creative
team then reshoot even more of the movie
because they didn't like what the
directors did your touch resulting in a
mixed bag that wasn't exactly great but
wasn't exactly terrible and if that's
how Disney plans to bring balance to the
force
just sit me up fam for example a family
that a patient of Hangzhou is probably
aged in a surfer that's less a han Solo
character stone and more the origin
story for all of Han Solo's accessories
like his God now go but hang on can we
rewind let's just look at that Han Solo
shot that one okay and now look at this
next one
why it's like they shot through
pantyhose like why it's dark and a man
just at night it's not just the
nighttime shots it's Everett that has
color that has vibrance and I'm not
talking about like what did it feel like
no why didn't it look like anything it
was like everything in this movie was
shot we'll get to it but just like was
the shot he's a rogue he operates in the
darkness great look I've seen I've seen
plenty of movies about assassins and
ninjas that run around at nighttime and
and do scoundrelly things and they're
shot well and you can see them ninja
assassins was 10 times darker than this
movie that movie was very dark these
can't be dark it's just this one seemed
dark for no reason
oh yeah these were supposed to be big
adventurous things you're on a barge
with this this big ship that's like
casino kind of lounge singer thing and
there's our two sons Suri and dart we're
putting that Tatooine that's a job I
just think in this in this movie and
this like thing flooded with sunlight
it's like this eggs and
like who's that in the but what's going
on I don't like I get it there and
Proxima Proxima Proxima mistress
midnight baby project which one of them
was how can Disney have two proximate
characters with one month mmm yes for
its Proxima midnight right from infinity
war wasn't that approximate oh yes my
lady problem whatever yeah great Mega
Man X characters I get it it's like
you're underground in this cave place
but you know Terminator the flashbacks
in Terminator where they're walking
around and you see the kids and he's
like does it you see it's same same
exact setting yeah and you see
everything you see absolutely everything
in those shots they're like lit well I
can see what's in the background I can
enjoy the detail I can enjoy the art
direction this is just blue well to me
the my problem with that seems that it
establishes something that nobody in the
original trilogy has ever had an
original idea in their life
most of all all the ideas from someone
else and that's where Leia stole the
thermal detonator thing from Han thank
you Kasdan said that in he tweeted like
here's some fun facts and he was like I
thought this beautiful an idea if he
told lay about the thermal detonator and
it's like I hate you Leia one time I was
talking to the big space worm it's true
everything you've heard me the space
worm the rock the Sun it's a version of
sunlight I picked up rocking said I was
gonna blow the place up and I hit the
road of my other girl for no I'm gonna
Bandhan you because the happy ending we
had just can't we'll be allowed to stand
goodbye we'll never speak again we
haven't even gotten to the color part
yet sorry alright keep playing like he's
gone yeah Millennium Falcon the little
militant is yet
his favorite gumbo they put that right
on the front dice since when were the
dice a big deal you didn't know they
were a big deal until now never look at
those tastes the same way again
suppose Jedi made this dessert awakens -
yeah the dice are big why I never in my
life I consider myself like a pretty big
star Wars fan particularly the original
films and I don't know if I ever in my
life notice that he had never did a
movie trip that needs to die is the
little memento remember me by thing yeah
and but it exists then they
screenwriters resort to it a lot and
because it's like an active way of
showing like oh I love you or whatever
in he's not gonna he's not gonna kiss
his vest
way better
if you pop to fess up just awkwardly
draped it over Leia is like don't forget
yep ghost Luke comes in yeah the dice
never really picks it up I never really
clocked the vest the dice until the
newer movies but yeah now I'll never
look very huge I felt like okay good
because I felt like a by the time I came
out of this movie I felt like a bad fan
how did I not notice that our fan base
loves its references to a tee
late 80s flash-in-the-pan comedians who
have had up and down acting careers all
turned ice sleigh hey yeah wait for my
whole Gallagher is Jar Jar yeah
good this is just smashing things okay
keep playing it was just a silly
background prob know everything needs an
explanation I don't have people I'm
lighting I was so like when he says Han
and he's like pushing buttons I was like
please don't say solo yeah so please
don't say solo
please don't say solo and there's like
soul oh my god it's awful it's the why
did you say that name of Star Wars to me
thinking so stupid like riding it they
were like the script the script [ __ ]
and then shooting it they're like it's
like it's like in my head I was like
they have to know that the hacky thing
in the world is for him to say solo so
they're setting it up for us to think
he's gonna say solo and then it's like
Han K are four five seven solo bird yeah
exactly or something and then he said
Solo is like are you kidding me I
accepted that it was gonna happen so I
was like maybe they'll do it good
somehow and then he said last name just
Han who were you people a question no
one has ever asked anyone in the history
of anything I don't have any people a
response no one has ever given I'm all
alone Han alone yeah that wasn't the the
cleverest it did his name need an
explanation just sounds cool why does he
have to fill out an imperial w-9 is
there a reason why he has to have a last
name they have operating numbers that's
what those operating numbers are for
yeah yeah also I never wondered what are
your hurting on a planet where everyone
is named Rick it's big galaxy there's
probably a planet where everybody's Rick
and now they're just all stormtroopers
yeah does this mean everyone's Star Wars
name is actually like a homonym for what
their family was doing at the time of
customs qui-gon what's your name Shmi
what's your last name I don't have one
look at you walking on air anyways
send us your garite oh yeah anyway so
let's keep watching
yes for this everyone's looked like to
face a bit more than reveal we're stuck
with a thankless job of playing a young
Harrison Ford the way though I think he
did a very good job like this I'm not
about to screw it up alright he'll add
new 2min he didn't do a selfish out long
pilot we met a new hope by showing this
he was never much of an outlaw and he
was never really that selfish but boy
did he have a hard-on for being a pilot
I'm gonna be a pilot I'm gonna be a
pilot this order myself have become a
pilot I'm a great pilot
I'll be your co-pilot we've already got
the pilot ok ok got the finger Hey yeah
you did get the point the hon point Oh
what's the the most important thing
about Han Solo according this movie he
wants to be a pilot what's the one thing
we don't see in this movie and becoming
a pilot well you know he piloted some
things he drove a convertible he drove a
car I can't fly 747 cuz I can park my
[ __ ] now it's a hovercraft that you're
piloting a hovercraft there was
something that I kept regret pilots
sound off the comments is it driving or
flying
it's a speeder they were in my notes
that I sent to you guys there was that
surprised me unless I didn't see it
unless people just didn't care enough
about this we're gonna have this
conversation but I found it very
interesting cuz he finally at the
Millennium Falcon yeah sliced the [ __ ]
out of it no one I heard no one say
after this movie
how come han solo gets behind the
controls the Millennium Falcon for the
first time and is able to get them
through the castle run the same way that
they said the exact same thing about
right yeah he's flipping it on five
seconds pinball never flown it before I
know he's just like when I was on these
ships when I was a kid when they were
getting billed but I mean that's
just--that's that is just as feasible as
people say like well Ray was a scavenger
she's been on a bunch of different kinds
of ships but I just thought that was
interesting that that narrative was
there just like no one was complaining
that Han Solo knew how to fly the lining
of [ __ ] in the front it says people
accept that he knows how to fly it but
again it's
since it's also aside from a hover car
Spencer the first time you see him fly a
spaceship at all in this movie and he's
just he's just a badass yeah Bobby's me
yeah cuz he wanted it so bad he wanted
to apologize but he would close his eyes
about piloting well and then Chewie sits
down next to him is this copilot and
they're like flipping switches and stuff
I'm like I know you will chew it by cuz
choose been around the block this is on
another case of forth like a minute
though you've got a new car and you're
like two weeks to find the headlights on
mine I'm like oh no that's not the
blinker that's the windshield wipers and
they're like what do we gotta go just
like no one there's gotta be something
close to standard cockpit organization
in Star Wars otherwise like you'd have
to get a new license every time you got
your [ __ ] I'm not saying that the movie
should explain that because I think
that's suspension of disbelief I'm just
saying that if you're gonna make that
point in one case then you should feel
point in the other case I think I'm
saying I think it's the only thing
regarding character development you're
gonna give a character that should be
what the developments about like that
should be what the movie is about is I
want to be a pilot they should have done
space Top Gun yeah yeah in the Academy
with some off being like I want some
BOTS and that should have been they
already had CG mothball just hanging out
yeah yeah just Tarkin being like if you
screw up just this much you'll be flying
a cargo freighter full of dog [ __ ] out
of Hong Kong
yeah yeah anyway so let's keep let's
keep going yeah I could pitch that okay
okay he wants to be a pilot we get it
all right anything else
what was his dad like he wanted to be a
pilot let's just go back to learning
about his accessories where you get that
best I don't know why that's my favorite
John like Chewbacca
who eats people know
Beckett I like what a hero star wouldn't
see it Kira
who's working for Paul Bettany but
really working with Han but really
working with Darth Maul he can serve
across the double cross he came from
across the double cross and had foul the
coolest new Star Wars character is never
mind Lando the Star Wars story we'd all
rather see except for that part where
he's clearly having sex with this droid
or an offensive satire evoke this
depending on which part of the internet
you like to scream at when han Solo was
the blandest character in your hunt so a
movie you've got a problem I'm hot 3:7 I
did not understand just what where they
were what they were attempting to do was
that yeah were they making fun of it or
were they like I think yeah that was a
testament to the movie to me was like
going online afterwards and you could
tell that both scream II camps also
clearly I guess didn't couldn't figure
out what the movie wanted to say with
that character because some people were
like totally burned those sjw's and then
other people were like thank God like it
I really liked how that droid spoke up
for rights and Tata me they weren't
thinking that hard like a lot of this
movie and I think why I enjoyed it I
also wasn't thinking very hard is it's
the comic relief robot droid every stars
movie has a funny droid in it now what's
ours gonna be oh this one's like like a
fake activists yeah that's funny it gets
laughs but that's the thing that was she
a fake activist or is she a real
activist there he want us to to agree
with her or laugh at her and I don't
think that movie ever made a part for us
in social internet sides from a
character standpoint the movie itself
seemed confused as it should you be
taking what seriously or should you be
laughing I think it wanted us to be
laughing at her because it's like okay
like she's self-aware but all these
other droids are like lowly animals so
like she's it's like the ridiculous PETA
people getting angry at the dreamer why
would you listen to me like it was
that's what they were going for it but
then like if you play a game of like
if this then what else yeah don't do
that but you can with the with a with
the originals like and even and even the
neutral like you you can like if if
Lando is super sad cuz his droid rights
robot died why does he hate droids or
why did not you didn't hate but why he's
so dismissive of c-3po and yeah you know
that was my favorite is like Landis like
cradling a dead l3 three sevens like
everybody to the ship we've got a saber
and then Empire Strikes Back
c3 peels like dismembered on a table is
just like something wrong with your
droid conjugal relations yes I guess a
certain bond is formed that and if
you're also if you're gonna lean in on
droids or slaves don't also lean in on
this man is having sex with his droid
slave but it was weird cause like she
was making him do it so it's okay he was
clearly not comfortable yeah it was not
his choice yeah which is also a can of
worms that we're not going to open this
on our trailer come tears play the tape
nobody cares did you want a darker take
on the Star Wars franchise well you've
got it because this one is so dark it's
hard to see what's happening whether the
action is hidden in deep blues muted
Brown's most of these are 10 to
15-minute sequences solid or Taco Bell
beef orange by the time your eyes adjust
you'll realize everyone in the galaxy is
lit like they're in witness protection
Oh Falcon I think yeah this movie is
literally the dark side so the
transition yeah that froze all the other
standalone projects in carbonite but
gave back a sense of how Han became the
character we all know and love by going
through the events of solo then at some
point off-camera before a new hub
becoming the character we all know and
love that could said he heard about this
very rehab relitigate in the grass truly
the most alluring argument we've ever
blown the star
grammar fights white man can't jump to
Lightspeed kill easy the sentient being
trapped inside the Falcon that's weird
sixes in a Wookiee
I want to Andy named this character you
can't can you tried in vos rally in like
haagen-dazs Samus Aran Terrace Kosti
that crabby PlayStation game is canon
now Oh singing ever attended fire
director in the middle of a production
he had a really good feeling about this
cowboy beef lob I like that title you
know if so isn't his birth name why did
he give it to his kid and the name him
after Luke's hermit friend who he knew
for like a day maybe no wonder he tossed
him off that bridge yeah Ben solo is not
so most appropriate name for that guy
son no Leia never met him right Obi one
yeah I mean she knew he knew of him yeah
she'd heard tales from dad they probably
met beforehand no cuz he was already I
know he was a hermit she sent him a
little I mean he was there when she was
born
yeah general Kenobi yeah we didn't even
talk about Chewie what's wrong Chewie
Chewie doesn't he ignored you sir he's
already 107 years old wasn't in the
movie was it but you're a l'heure clip
of like you're how old
no that's in there yeah with the
actually that may I think that may have
been how they got around the fact that
Chewie knows how to operate the Falcon I
think we need now that I think about he
sits down he's like how do you know how
to do this he's like 900 or what yeah
like was the life dead in this movie I
couldn't tell if that is that the life
debt that he sort of got him out of that
talk to out of the whole low bar for
like oh yeah you can't be hanging handed
out left it's candy yeah I guess that
was the liked it because later on he
encounters his family and like leaves
them to go with Han so that when you
talk about the Christmas special no I
don't blame you for not being able to
see them or what
very very difficult to tell also their
mind the fact that Han speaks Wookiee
and never does never does again that's
highly problematic yeah it just also
refuses to say his full name it's just
weird
it's weird that they just Bacchus Tula
I've never had a problem with the fact
he called him Chewie it's just cause
they're familiar and they're pals and
the fact that he's like no your name is
too long for in person I'm calling you
Chewie it's like okay I think there's
just reverse engineering I well you
didn't need it
again I'm saying you didn't need to
explain the reason if it's good then why
do I do it yeah you don't need to really
like show the pipe on how you got there
cuz it's like my name is Alexander hey
Alex like that's fine you don't need to
be like I'm gonna call you Alex because
Alexander is two more syllables yeah if
in two scenes he was on the train you
like Joey yeah well I guess I benefited
from just not watching very closely
because I was mostly working on Doctor
Who that week you guys really carried
the load on this one Estevez did lawn
Harris but I enjoyed it I was like oh
fun space romp you know I think if you
just unfocus your eyes you're in Star
Wars han Solo and so far you're
squinting at the screen do that I guess
I don't know III agree with me Spencer
for as far as arcs go like looking for
the arc of how Han Solo became Han Solo
it's like if Han Solo was always just
like kind of an immature roguish little
rapscallion teenage [ __ ] then fine
he's he's the guy who never grew up like
he just is was always that kid and in
the original trilogy like he didn't have
he didn't need an arc because he grows
in in force awakens that's when he
really grew up was in his 40s which is
super special which is very different
well I mean he grows up in the original
trilogy when he comes back that would it
was then shown to be like a one-time
thing back to smuggling tentacle monster
yeah I agree if he had no arc and you
had just done an ensemble thing and it's
like that guys the archetype of the
[ __ ] yeah cool movie I'm fine with
that it's him and younger Ito and
Beckett and Candide Newton running
around shooting people and stealing
things yeah if the whole movie been the
Train would've been fine with that long
train right long train ride
I'd watch like a Murder on the Orient
Express but it's a space train also
we're still going with trains in the in
a world of spaceships still drive it
still on rosier to hide i guess cuz it
was so volatile there was like a really
damage it supported by train there was a
really dim imperial governor on that
plane and a guy lena it was like I have
a monorail to sell you babies like the
teens gonna love me yeah that's another
good Star Wars stories the inner Glenn
or else's very volatile fuel how should
we transport it what about a train that
twister coaster every turn could we just
fly it above these mountains no no no no
train clearly designed to be a roller
coaster to come Disney's new Star Wars
Park yeah yeah anyway so we have any
admits here some starring right good at
radio DJ style strap it Han joins a gang
of even scruffier nerf herders like
Chewbacca a republic war hero who went
from working with Yoda to being this
two-bit Imperial drug mules assistant
starring James T smirk John solo here
for every solo the creature in the Black
Lagoon
Chewbacca man it's way too long and
difficult to say Chewie
won-ho syllable shorter way way better
she stay warm on Lando sweep in Caped
Crusader childish Canberra Sein
pansexual chocolate
r.i.p most interesting character in the
movie Wow Scarface taser face scar vez
Jarvis the hut riding through this world
skies of anarchy old man mall
Darth Maul a graham the litmus test for
whether you watch rebels or Clone Wars
scruffy flush Gordon so long to Star
Wars stories what would you do if the
person you most trusted he's always good
betrayed you hey to clarify which world
do you trust wrong you've been on to in
this movie alone yes galaxy yes Oh No is
he gonna make it
what if you he died in this movie and
they just read Khan the entire ot yeah
you never really thought you Baca was
good yeah pretty cool like The Hobbit
does the same thing like all of the
major character and peril things are
like Legolas and Gandalf
you're like they're fine they're fine
I'm gonna see the very but what it mmmm
now if you have fili and Kili get the
crap kicked out of them by that big orc
vana about Muffy leave them died yes not
that one not yeah what was it feeling
anyone kili kili or Deeley or Gigli we
should talk more about Gigli someday
yeah but that day is not today not today
do we have any final solo thoughts no I
think we run the spectrum I think we run
the gamut of like enjoyed it very
indifferent and really not liking it
I'm glad knowing us all this movie yeah
well it's because of the boycott right
Joe yeah absolutely because of the
boycott
yeah hundred thousand thousand strong at
least there won't
girls in this was I the only one that
thought that l33 seven is that her name
yeah delete leat without the only one
that would thought that that was Tilda
Swinton like until a week ago when I
look very excited Tilda Swinton super
Swinton I was convinced I didn't even
look at the credits I didn't had a check
that's how confident I was that that was
Tilda Swinton and then I felt Berenstein
bird yeah now the timeline split and in
one universe that's Tilda Swinton yeah
not this ya know the one would tell that
she was like I have to see the script
before I do it and she fixed it you
think you tilde from another room thank
you for your service
Tilda prime all right left and we'll be
back next week for is a 0% chance
there's a 0% chance you've seen this one
you see this yeah but you'll enjoy it
nonetheless yes I think guys the pass
yeah that's all you're gonna get yeah
see you then bye bye today's episode was
brought to you by the US Army find out
more by clicking the link below
you